.
de rue. Selon les autorités
policièiennes,
jamais la ville n'avait connu
pareille opération de protection
des quatre coins de la planète.
JEAN CHRÉTIEN
premier ministre du Canada
- C'était une perse à travers le
depuis très longtemps.
Et mon expérience, je l'ai
rencontrée au Canada, mais
beaucoupCommonwealth. Évidemmen,
elle était toujours en vedette
quand elle arrivait.
- Quelques 2000 personnes
aux funérailles à l'abbaye
de Westminster. Parmi elles,
500 dignitaires étrangers.
L'occasion de rencontres
... et formelles.
Comme ces réunions bilatérales
australien...
beaucoup.
-... et Ukrainien.
par égard au deuil national,
Justin Trudeau s'est rendu a
10 Downing Street pour
s'entretenir avec la nouvelle
Elle représente la droite
du parti conservat
britannique. Leurs politiques
ne sont pas toutes alignées,
partagent un intérêt marqué
pour le sort de l'
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
premier ministre du Canada
continuons d'être parmi les pays
les plus en appui
évidemment aux actions illégales
et immorales de la
- Justin Trudeau ainsi que
d'autres dignitaires étrangers
offerte par Charles III
au Palais de Bucki
Bien que le nouveau monarque ait
été préparé toute sa vie
n'a pas suivi. Cela pourrait-il
fragiliser les lie
la monarchie au Canada?
Justin Trudeau n'a aucune
- On est dans tellement un
moment c compliqué
que de faire un changement aussi
profond dans un système qui est
les plus stables dans le monde.
Maintenaoi,
ce n'est pas une bonne idée.
- Aux yeux de Justin Trudeau,
c'est d'abord et a
la stabilité et la continuité
qui importent, au-delà du niveau
N'empêche, la pression est
sûremeur les épaules
de Charles III, après tant
d'hommages rendus à sa mère,
Ici Madeleine Blais-Morin,
Radio-Canada, Londres.
Raphaël aux abor